now Banks should be evaluating you
before they give you the mortgage but
there were mortgage brokers that were
pushing qualifications to the edge
because they had to do something you
know what they had to do they had to get
homes for their clients yeah and they
had to eat because if they didn't if
they didn't sell a mortgage they don't
need that's how they make money and a
lot of that went down so they weren't
making as much money so what ends up
with this is scary bankruptcy is up 20
62 percent so if you're out there and
you're having trouble God bless you I
hope you can surf this happen now is it
time to be very conservative and to be
in control